there's a story I wanted to get to
yesterday that I do not want to skip
over amid the more pressing and
depressing news it is a new story more
shocking than anything we have seen even
in the tumultuous recent weeks a
Democrat has been held accountable for
his crimes sort of at least a little bit
Democrat Congressman Jamal Bowman who
last March called me a Nazi hellbent on
keeping only white men alive and in
power has been indicted for falsely
pulling a fire alarm at the US capital
He was ordered to report to Capital
Police Headquarters yesterday to be
booked fingerprinted photographed and
processed and the charge carries a
maximum penalty of 6 months in jail
which Bowman will never serve because
actually here's the best part he's
pleading guilty and therefore he's just
paying a fine and apologizing while it
might be fun to send him to jail I'm
actually more satisfied by the guilty
plea because the guilty plea proves that
Congressman Bowman who initially denied
the crime is in fact a Shameless liar
did I mention he called me a Nazi back
in March yeah he admitted to being a big
fat
liar also it proves that the Democrats
who defended him are either dupes or
Shameless hacks here is AOC there he is
uh pulling the fire alarm he says it was
an accident he thought pulling the alarm
would open a door uh based on the fact
that the doors to his right there were
locked and there was a sign that he said
he was I think someone said it was
confusing I'll be honest that doesn't
really make sense to me his explanation
have you talked to
him what's going on there I mean listen
I think if you actually do see some of
the photos of the signs I think there's
there's something to be said about the
government's about to shut down there's
a vote clock that's going down the exits
that are normally open in that building
were suddenly
closed pull the fire so I'm I'm what I
am here to say is that house
administration and US capital police and
Jamal Bowman are an active and he's
fully participating and saying there was
a misunderstanding but what I do think
is important to raise is the fact that
Republicans Representatives like Nicole
motakis and others immediately moved to
file motions to censure motions to expel
before there before there has even been
conversations that are that are finished
to even see if there was
misunderstanding here AOC to her credit
at least seemed half-hearted in her
defense of the indefensible Bowman the
liberal ladies of The View on the other
hand seemed intent on mounting a serious
defense I don't want to call it a stunt
yet there's going to be an investigation
I know Jamal and so again I'm a little
biased but the doors that are normally
open so that he could get to the
chambers to read Were Somehow
miraculously closed how did that happen
and so yes sometimes you're freaking
elev you were saying it goes to them not
having the time it is quite possible
that he was trying to get there and and
the door not panic but you know if
you're not looking because it's a door
that's normally open you just go and you
press a button you know fire alarm
button like I'm so scared of I I don't
know because I don't know what it I I
haven't seen the fire long button so I
don't it wasn't like fire exit only sign
it was because you have to break glass
to press the to get to the button so I
don't know I don't know it seems pretty
fire alarming to me I don't know it just
looks like a butt I can't see the butt
yeah the fire alarm looked pretty clear
to Bowman at least his Bowman pulled it
to obstruct an official Congressional
procedure a crime for which Midwestern
Granny's have been sent to rot in
solitary confinement the guilty Playa is
a good start now it's time for newly
empowered House Republicans and at least
to censure Mr Bowman at least and better
still to boot him out of Congress I'm
Michael nolles this the Michael NS
[Music]
show welcome back to the show a young
lady has gone viral for whining about
her 9-to-5 job and everyone's making fun
of her especially all the conservative
pundits
and I'm kind of on her side actually
we'll get kind of we'll get to it in a
second first though speaking of that
newly empowered house Republican
caucus the new Republican Speaker of the
House Mike
Johnson the hits just keep on coming
this guy opened up his tenure as
Speaker by speaking directly and
explicit about God I want to tell all my
colleagues here what I told the
Republicans in that room last night I
don't believe there are any coincidences
in a manner like this I I believe that
scripture the Bible is very clear that
that God is the one that raises up those
in Authority he raised up each of you
all of us and and I believe that God has
ordained and allowed each one of us to
be brought here for this specific moment
in this time this is my belief I believe
that each one of us has a huge
responsibility today to use the gifts
that God has given us to serve the
Extraordinary People of this great
country and they deserve it beautifully
put for the Christian there is no such
thing as a mere coincidence for a
Christian the world is Rich and teeming
with symbols for a Christian history has
meaning for a Christian God enters into
history not only directs history from
far away but actually enters into
history and becomes the very pivot of
history
and everything has its purpose and God
knows every hair on your head before
you're born and there is no such thing
as a mere coincidence that's really
really important all nature is but art
unknown to thee all chance Direction
which thou CST not see we are called to
act in the world we are called also to
interpret our Lord says that a wicked
generation seeks after signs and wonders
and to that generation no sign shall be
given none but the sign of Jonah which
is the sign of a man in the belly of the
whale for 3 days and it's the very sign
of our Lord's Resurrection in the
meaning of history in the in the bowels
of Hell harrowing hell resurrected on
the third
day all of this coming from the
speaker's chair is likely to rankle some
feathers of the more secular set but
this is my favorite part about the whole
thing because what Mike Johnson said
there would have been totally normal no
one would have batted an eyelash for the
first 230 years years of our nation's
history for a speaker of the house to
invoke God directly and to point out
that history has meaning and that we're
here for a purpose and and to to point
out the the symbols that that exist in
all of our daily lives no one would that
would have been totally normal you heard
all of this this kind of God talk for
all of our Nations history until
starting in the middle of the 20th
century the atheists and the secularists
started to creep in and tried to pretend
that somehow the First Amendment
banishes God for public life of course
nothing could be further from the truth
and it's really important for Mike
Johnson to speak this way because not
only do the Liberals want to banish God
from public life but there are a lot of
fashionable conservatives who who think
that it's kind of low class it's kind of
it doesn't it's just kind of deplorable
and irredeemable and icky to talk about
God we need to speak look we need to
make our arguments in secular terms we
need we're we got to cut it out with the
God talk we might believe in God in our
own private lives in the recesses of our
mind but we got to we got to make our
arguments in secular
terms why to appease the left which is
wrong about virtually everything why
would we do that I hear this I hear this
from self-styled conservatives all the
time look I'm going to make my Arguments
for x or y policy issue in secular terms
why why would you do that if you make
your arguments in terms that deny the
existence of God you're probably going
to go wrong because that's the first
principle man that's the that's the most
basic question that there is and if you
get the most basic question wrong you're
probably going to go pretty pretty far
off the rails pretty quickly I love that
what we're seeing here with Mike Johnson
which seems so radical he seems like the
most Rock ribbed hardcore conservative
ever to sit in the speaker's chair and
in in recent years I guess he is but
what he represents is a return to normal
what he represents is a return to sanity
that has that has typified
the American government for most of our
nation's history that is typified
Western governments broadly for most of
our history but these days in our absurd
times
seems bizarre seems very unusual the
other strong evidence that this guy
knows what he's doing is a picture from
speaker Johnson's youth where he's
standing I I suppose that's his wife and
and they're taking a picture together
and you may have seen a meme going
around that measures a man virility and
masculinity by whether or not he is
standing up straight while the woman in
the picture or I guess even the man in
the picture is leaning into him whoever
is leaning the most is the subserviant
person in the relationship and whoever
is standing up the straightest whoever
is is most in composure of himself that
would be the alpha in the relationship
this according to the internet and
there's this picture where
Mike Johnson taking a photo with this
beautiful lady who I assume to be his
wife and she is totally leaning in to
Mike Johnson Mike Johnson not only
standing up straight he's actually
leaning back a little bit this is a
degree of Sigma chatty this is a degree
of virility uh here to for unknown to
scientists and it to me aures well of
what will come in his speakership and we
got to talk about these important issues
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to peer talk.com peer talk recently
announced that they would alleviate $10
million in veteran debt by Veterans Day
thanks to your support last week Pure
Talk is
53% toward that goal with two weeks to
go now just think about this we have a
100% volunteer military men and women
who raise their hands to sacrifice for
our country and when they're done
serving they come back to a tight job
market and an outrageous cost of living
expenses that is one of the many reasons
that I'm so happy a private company like
Pur talk has jumped in to help when you
switch to P Talk's Lightning Fast 5G
Network they will donate a portion of
every new order to this noble cause you
can make a real difference just by
choosing Superior sell service pure
talks plan start at just 20 bucks a
month offering unlimited talk text more
data and a mobile hotspot just go to Pur
talk.com kwes to make the switch let's
rally together and show our unwavering
support for our veterans go to Pur
talk.com switch to p talk today it is
the right move and it's the American way
speaking of women a woman has gone viral
for whining about her job this clip
thanks as always to our friends over at
Libs of Tik Tock everybody is making fun
of this woman here's why I know I'm
probably just being so dramatic and
annoying but this is my first job like
my first 9 to-5 job after college and
I'm in person and I'm commuting in the
city and it takes me forever to get get
there there's no way I'm going to be
able to afford living in the city right
now so that's off the table like if I
was able to walk to work and it it'd be
fine but I'm not so it literally takes
me like I leave here like I get on the
train at 7:30 and I don't get home till
like 6:15 earliest and then like I don't
have time to do anything I don't I want
to shower eat my dinner and go to sleep
I don't have time or energy to cook by
dinner either like I don't have energy
to work out like that's out the window
like I'm so upset oh my God nothing to
do with my job at all but just like the
9 to5 schedule in general is crazy being
in the office 9 to5 like if it was
remote you get off at 5:00 and you're
home and everything's fine but like I'm
not home it takes me long to get home
and like like people that drive to the
office like it doesn't you don't get off
at 5: and I know it could be worse I
know I could be working longer but like
I literally get off it's pitch black
like I don't have energy how do you have
friends like how do you have time to
like meet like a guy I don't know like
how do you have time for like dating
like I don't have time for anything and
I'm like so stressed out and I'm also
getting my period so that's why I'm all
emotional but like am I so dramatic it's
fine why are people making fun of her I
don't everything she said was right she
opens up she says hey I'm probably going
to sound really annoying and overly
dramatic here but anyway I'm going to
complain about my job because the cities
are too expensive to live in now and it
feels unnatural for me a lady to be
working in exactly the same way that a
man is which is true for most of human
history that would never have happened
but because of feminism we have to
pretend that men and women are exactly
the same she goes and I don't really
like that that doesn't make me feel good
or normal in any way and then I got to
commute all the way back and I do this
job I don't really like this job and I
I'm not getting paid enough so I can't
live closer so it makes it even harder
then I come back and I don't don't
really have much time for a life and
it's very hard to date it is is very
hard to date for young people especially
in this
stupid feminist society and and Mal
ordered economy and then she says and by
the way you know I'm also just I'm I'm
about to men straight so I'm probably
just being irrational which is also
probably true I I I give her not a 10
out of 10 but a nine out of 10 in the
arguments that she's
making the part that people are really
making fun of is that she's complaining
about working a 9 to5 because a lot of
people work a lot more than a 9 to5
though her argument is well it's more
than a 9o5 because I got to leave my
house an hour and a half before I
actually get there and I get back an
hour and a half later so it ends up
being not an 8 hour job but more like a
10 or 11 hour job and and that's true
but even on that point I think she's
getting at something really important
which is it is important to do your job
with
purpose many people listening right now
do not work 9 to5 many people listening
right now maybe most don't work just
eight hours a
day they work 9 or 10 or 11 or 12 I
couldn't tell you the last time I worked
eight hours a
day but then again I can't tell you the
last time I worked because my job
doesn't really feel like work but some
of the time it feels like work but a lot
of the time it doesn't because I'm doing
something that I feel is purposeful and
has meaning and I enjoy it or at the
very least even if I'm not actively
enjoying it at any given moment I'm
deriving some deal of satisfaction and
ratification from it and this can be
true of any job you can consecrate any
kind of work even the sort of work that
Elites would sneer at and say is
meaningless or drudge work or menial uh
no you can consecrate that work to God
you can you can find profound meaning in
that I mean a classic example of this is
if all of the journalists suddenly
disappeared from the earth tomorrow
nothing would change if all of the
plumbers or sanitation workers
disappeared from The Earth Society would
come to a grinding halt within about 12
hours there's deep meaning in that even
though in our society we we deny such a
thing and we pretend that the only work
that matters is I don't know Hollywood
or journalists or some wacko academics
in their Ivory Towers but no there there
there has to be meaning there but so the
the issue that she's complaining about
is not just uh my job is annoying
sometimes which is an issue that every
single person who has ever lived will
deal with the issue that she's she's
complaining about is the DAR of meaning
which ties right back in with with what
we were talking about when it comes to
speaker
Johnson if you think that there's no
point to life that we're just here to
feel pleasure at any given moment you're
going to be miserable most of the time
because you got to work you got to work
at your job you got to work on your
personal relationships you got to work
in your home you got to you got to work
by the sweat of our brow we will we will
have our
food if you think there is a a purpose
though which is okay I'm not just going
to date aimlessly I'm going to get
married and I'm not just going to be in
a partnership like the Liberals talk
about today but I'm going to have a real
family and I'm going to have kids if I'm
blessed to have kids and I'm going to
raise those kids and I'm going to do so
for a purpose because I think that we're
here to uh be fruitful and multiply and
to flourish in our communities and to
pursue the good and to glorify God
you're going to have a much easier time
and that hour job is going to feel a lot
shorter and that 12-hour job is going to
feel like an 8 hour job and you're not
going to be concerned about uh all the
time you feel you're wasting in fact
you're going to feel like there isn't
enough time at all now speaking of young
women talking about their work in in
viral videos I have to turn our
attention to uh gret tunberg who appears
to have gone viral I say that
intentionally she appears to have gone
viral uh
giving her thoughts on how to proceed in
the upcoming world war war is always bad
specifically for the planet if we want
to continue uh fighting battles like
environmentally conscious humans we must
make the change to sustainable tanks and
weaponry there are so many new Concepts
for uh batterypowered fighter jets that
can carry many more um missiles
biodegradable missiles of course
something literally everybody can do to
stop this nonsense is for example block
the roads to Gardens and Farms so the
plants don't get overrun by these heavy
heavy tanks hand grenades very important
if you use hand grenades please use
vegan grenades no animal should have to
give their life for all this Mayhem and
Chaos they have a special sticker on
them you really can't miss them in the
uh grenade Market or wherever you buy
them yeah I cover all of this and More
in my newest book Vegan Wars vegan Wars
this video had me going until the vegan
grenades and then I looked around and
it's pretty well labeled it says AI
humor and even though it says BBC
and it's really good this is a really
good deep fake it's not 100% of the way
there but it's I don't know 94 95% of
the way there and and this is another
issue where the chattering class is
boning their their rending their
garments over the spread of Deep fakes I
think deep fakes are great I'm I'm all
for the Deep fakes obviously they could
be abused but the thing I like about the
Deep fakes is they deplete the power of
gotcha moments they deplete the power of
you know you you get a decent political
candidate but then I don't know they
said something unto and they got caught
on camera doing it 20 years ago and so
now that's going to ruin their lives
with with deep fakes now totally
pervasive people are going to question e
even the videos that they're seeing
before their very eyes and so while this
might lead some to a kind of radical
skepticism I think the society's already
at the stage of radical skepticism we
deny objective truth we believe all
sorts of cockamamy things like the
notion that so I'm not I'm not worried
about the spread of skepticism what I
like about the Deep fakes is that it
Tunes Us in more closely to what is
going on right now to to the tangible to
the local to the things with which we
have a direct connection so that we're
not merely being hypnotized by the mass
media which is probably the number one
tool of of hypnotism of control by the
political Elite I'm all for it bring on
those deep fakes and bring on those
vegan hand grenades now as the political
order Goes Up in Smoke you're probably
going to want some tangible assets
speaking of things you can hold on to
and that's why you want to check out
Birch gold right now text nolles to 9898
98 the G20 or group of 20 is an
international forum for governments and
Central Bank Governors it was
established in response to the financial
crisis of the late 1990s with the aim of
promoting International Financial
stability last month the G20 announced a
plan to impose digital currencies and
digital IDs on their respective
populations Central Bank digital
currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase you
make even if you don't follow
International economic policies closely
you should be concerned and you should
consider diversifying at least some of
your assets into physical gold with the
help of Birch gold group call Birch gold
today to preserve your savings in a tax
sheltered retirement account if you have
an IRA or 401K from a previous employer
call Birch gold and they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you won't
pay a penny out of pocket they will
simply convert that 401k that would
otherwise be sitting in a bank somewhere
into physical gold which can't be
tampered with Tex nolles Canada to 998
9898 Birch gold will send you a free
info kit on gold if digital currency
becomes a reality you will be glad that
you have something physical to fall back
on text Noles kwes to 98 9898 and claim
your free info kit on gold today folks
when we talk about really valuable
things I've got the top of the list you
can now get the limited edition Michael
nolles pumpkin spice candle here it is
don't wait we sold out once we then
massively ordered as many as we could
it's still pretty tight but we're
producing them as quickly as the little
the little pumpkin patch hands can can
make them order your candles now they
are only available during pumpkin spice
season at dailywire.com
shop oh wow delish also I've been
burning this candle constantly for a
very long time now and there's still a
fair bit of candle left this is a very
well-made candle artisanal pumpkin spice
candles speaking of political violence
uh there's a troubling survey out which
is from the public religion Research
Institute and Brooking uh Brookings
which shows that one in four Americans
believe political violence is Justified
to save the
country and this headline is going
everywhere this say here we go we're
descending into civil war and violence
and usually it's being blamed on those
Maga right-wing Republican terrorists
who were trying to kill
everybody what does the survey really
say says today about 23% of Americans
just a little under 1 and4 agree that
quote because things have gotten so far
off track true American Patriots may
have to resort to violence in order to
save our country this is up from 15% in
2021 in principle that statement is
always true in every state everywhere
around the world for all of history
this is a point I made a while ago that
I got in trouble for making when it was
some crazy Democrat New Mexico Governor
tried to uh suspend certain laws by
saying we're essentially in a time of
Crisis and we have to uh we have to
ignore certain rights and Liberties uh
because we Face an existential threat
and at the time what got me in trouble
was I said what she is doing is wrong
she was suspending some some part of gun
rights in in Albuquerque or something I
said what she is actually doing
practically is wrong and is not
defensible but the principle that she is
articulating is a true enough principle
because ultimately if the political
order breaks down then extraordinary
powers necessarily will be invoked to
preserve it and this notion was defended
by the American founding fathers was
defended for goodness sakes by Thomas
Jefferson who was the most classically
liberal-minded of the prominent founding
fathers who wrote the Declaration of
Independence but this is always true
it's just as true is this principle here
if the political order breaks down there
will be political
violence and in fact a a the the
exercise of political violence will be
justified to preserve the order just as
extraordinary political Powers will be
justified so that the entire political
system doesn't collapse I'm not
recommending this I'm not saying we're
in this time now I'm not encouraging
anybody to take that up I'm not looking
forward to a time when the political
order breaks down and political violence
becomes more
popular don't shoot the messenger I'm
just observing that is necessarily what
will happen throughout all of history
and some people a little bit on the
right but mostly on the left are very
Cavalier about all of that I mean the
left openly promotes political violence
through terrorist groups like antifa and
BLM and in recent weeks I guess Hamas
they're they're all for political
violence targeting
civilians but
that kind of chaos that kind of Anarchy
will inevitably result in more violence
and the in fact the only way to justify
it would be to to uh use it in order to
preserve the political order but that
gets very dicey very very quickly and
the people who are clamoring for civil
war or armed Insurrection or anything
like that mostly on the left but
occasionally you hear a little bit on
the right I fear they do not know what
they are signing up for
because Ju Just as we're sleepwalking
toward World War III in Ukraine and in
the Middle East so too we hear this at
home oh yes we're on the brink of Civil
War we need a national divorce we need
we need partition yeah when has that
ever happened
peacefully wouldn't be so Cavalier about
that man now speaking of political
violence and the outbreak of World War
II there is a conflict right now there's
a genocide that is going on right now
that is not making very many headlines
we hear about the conflict in Ukraine we
hear about the conflict in Gaza and the
state of Israel we hear about potential
genocides from both sides especially in
Gaza in the state of
Israel you probably haven't heard very
much about the nagorno kabach conflict
which is a conflict between Armenia and
aeran aeran Muslim country Armenia a
Christian country not only a Christian
country the oldest Christian country in
the world a country that
converted at a at a national level to
Christianity in the early 4th century
and right
now aeran not only ethnically cleansed a
territory formerly held by the Armenians
negoro caraba but uh now threatens The
Armenian people more broadly so how did
this
happen
aeran claimed this territory the ngoran
carabat because Stalin and the Soviet
Union came in and conquered aeran and
Armenia and
Stalin essentially gave this territory
to aeran then the Soviet Union collapses
then there's conflict over the territory
there's a ceasefire in 1994 and in 1994
this region full of Armenians but not
within the borders of what we now call
present day Armenia declares itself the
Republic of artach and is allowed to
exist in practice as an independent
state within aeran then 16 years more
than 16 years later uh 26 years later I
guess the conflict gets a little bit hot
again in 2020 there were border clashes
it ends with aeran coming in and taking
big portions of the Republic of artac
which is sort of Armenia but not exactly
Armenia but it's fulled with Armenians
but even Armenia wouldn't recognize the
independence of the Republic of artach
then then what
happened the Aeris continue to get more
and more aggressive against the
Armenians why because Russia which had
had been under Stalin one of the causes
of this conflict had actually been the
peacekeepers but Russia got bogged down
in the Ukraine war had Russia just gone
in and ended the Ukraine war within two
weeks you probably wouldn't have seen
this break out or it wouldn't have
gotten as bad as it did but because
Russia ended up getting bogged down in
the war in Ukraine which is still
ongoing the conflict begins to Fester
now aeran comes in and blockades the
taking I'm probably mispronouncing that
Corridor and cuts off negoro carab back
from the outside world so cuts off these
Armenians from the outside world and all
the kinds of atrocities that you hear
about the the starvation the blockades
the death the rape the violence you hear
about coming from this region so then
what
happens now things are are even dicier
Israel which is a US Ally took the side
of aeran why did is this is my biggest
complaint against the state of Israel in
recent years Israel takes a side of
aeran because
aeran is an ally of or is is an opponent
rather of Iran and Iran is the biggest
enemy of Israel so Iran a Muslim country
takes the side of Armenia the Christian
country against the other Muslim country
aeran
Russia which had been to some degree
protecting the rights of the Armenians
could come in now and take the side of
aeran because aeran seems to be winning
the conflict what about turkey what
about what is the United States's role
here I for one as an American would like
to see us protect the Armenians out of
Christian solidarity if for nothing
else but where does it all
stand it all shows you the complex of
foreign policy which Everyone likes to
spout off on the minute any conflict
breaks out Everyone likes to you know
have a hyperfocus on the conflicts that
are are the big headline stories in the
news but these kind of conflicts even up
to the point of genocide happen all over
the world and they happen much more
regularly than we would like to admit
and this is crucial if the war in the
Middle East expands as it seems like it
will you could trigger so many other
conflicts that you could be in a world
war a true World War involving a huge
number if not most nations of the
Earth in the blink of an
eye what happens if the war in Israel
and Gaza expands to include Iran what is
that going to mean for Armenia and aeran
and Russia and we haven't even talked
about China what's it going to mean in
Ukraine what's it going to mean for the
United States how
quickly could we go from bad to much
much worse it's much more to talk about
before we get to the
mailbag first
though you've been asking us for an
alternative in kids media now it's
finally here the daily wire has just
launched bent key our brand new kids
platform we're all sick of Hollywood
pushing a leftist propaganda agenda on
our kids now here is an answer for those
of us looking for kids shows that we can
trust bent key is brand new it's
available to download right now it's an
entirely new company from the daily wire
dedicated to creating the next
generation of Timeless stories that
transport kids into a world of Adventure
imagination and joy the content is
phenomenal high quality fun my kids love
it this stuff I already had high
expectations for it this totally
exceeded my
expectations I could never have imagined
that the daily wire was going to provide
all of this for its members without
increasing the price of the annual
membership in fact I think we should
have increased the price of annual
membership but hey I don't make these
decisions and daily wire wanted to give
a huge value ad for the me members this
is a $99 value you get completely for
free what that goes to show is that we
don't just talk about changing culture
we put it into action we really believe
in what we're doing and as I said if
you're already a dw+ member you already
have bent key just download the app to
start streaming now if you're not a
member there's never been more value to
joining than right this second you get
all of the dw+ content that you know and
love Plus benty at no additional cost go
to dailywire.com subscribe right now to
start streaming the next generation of
kids
entertainment my favorite comment
yesterday is from Demolition Man
5003 who says wow so we live in the USSR
now that was so coerced you can tell
that the government basically said do
this or your life is over yes speaking
of Stalin speaking of the
USSR uh the the confession from Jenna
was was so depressing
not not because of whatever it means for
Jenna not because of what it means for
Trump's defense that his former lawyer
is taking a plea deal I'm not not
because any any of us would have
necessarily done any differently because
of what it says about the regime it
feels like we are living in the Soviet
Union there's so much more I want to get
to there's so much more to say
today but we got to get to the mail bag
this mail bag is sponsored by palk go PE
talk.com NOS kwes today take it away all
right Michael I have a weird one for you
so I get my dog groomed um kind of
regularly every few months mons and
she's kind of crazy to put it mildly
we've gone through a few groomers and
just recently I found one that I really
like she has great customer service
she's great with my dog my dog likes her
um she gets the job done no
issues and I started noticing that she
has a lot of like ult looking
tattoos which was kind of weird to me
and curiosity got the better of me and I
went and looked her up on Facebook and
sure enough she's like an avowed
Satanist
anyway I don't know if I just should
have minded my business on that um I
don't really know where to go from here
I don't know if I feel comfortable doing
business with somebody who's a Satanist
I just want to know what you would do
Michael any advice would be great
thanks I would not have a dog I feel
totally Vindicated now in my relatively
anti-dog stance is this is what happens
you get a dog you get the cute little
Pooch and then all of a sudden you're
doing business with
satanists uh but if I had a
dog I would not do business with a
Satanist in any circumstance but but
before you fire her you might ask about
the
tattoos you know you bring your dog
there dogs don't have Immortal Souls so
you don't need to worry about you know
any any terrible things happening to
your dog but you could go there and say
hey what's that tattoo
mean people get tattoos because they
want to talk about them no one gets a
tattoo because they don't want to talk
about whatever the tattoo represents
they they got it permanently etched onto
their body it's something they want to
talk about they want they want it to be
noticed so you could ask about it and
then you could use it as an opportunity
to
evangelize not saying you necessarily
are obligated to do that and to go you
know make a disciple of every dog RoR in
the world but it would be good thing to
do so you could you could do that and
then worst case you fire her and and
what's the worst thing she does she
tries to like put a hex on you or
something well who cares your you know
your God beats all the demons and the
devil so that's okay but you could you
could use that as an opportunity next
question hello Michael sending my
readings from the beautiful Croatia I
hope you will come one day to do a
speech I'm still waiting to get my
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds book signed uh but I'm here on
this mailbag to actually bring some good
good good news to you actually which is
quite rare I know so my friend works in
a kindergarten and he just sent me today
uh a page from questions which they
grade their kids uh maturity and this
specific question was in regards to
their emotional maturity and one of the
points which actually brings it up is uh
the child knows that he will grow up to
be a man or a woman that he CH that
he by dressing or having long hair so he
can't
be by aesthetically looking like even
though they don't usually look like
either one uh yeah this really made me
happy today I hope you enjoy your week
the next week the weekend because it's a
Friday and yeah peace hope to see you
one
day I loved hearing that that message
that really did set off my weekend in a
great
way one because I love that the show is
making it to Croatia that is great that
is absolutely fabulous but two just
underscores the point that Eastern
Europe is the Hope Eastern Europe which
was once dominated by the Communists
actually maybe because it was dominated
by the Communists keep
producing these much more conservative
societies you think of Hungary Hungary
is the leader in Europe for conservatism
you think of Poland Poland's pretty good
Croatia now too Croatia knows the
difference that's great news maybe we in
the west need to look East a little bit
to learn some lessons that apparently
kindergarteners already know next
question hi Michael big fan of the show
so if we were to remove your political
views from the equation and you were to
meet the other daily wire hosts out in
the world outside of the daily wire do
you think that you would still be
friends and if so on what basis thanks
yes in fact I know that
because that is what happened because we
were friends before the daily wire
existed so at least
uh at least me Jeremy Ben and Drew were
all friends before daily wire existed I
guess we met Candace kind of came on the
scene after the daily wire existed but
we we did become friends not not only
when we started working together but
years before that uh Matt too Matt was
around he was in a different I think he
was living in Texas no he was living in
the the Hilter lands somewhere of
Maryland or Pennsylvania or something um
in the early days of daily wire but yeah
yeah we would I guess the only part of
your question that doesn't make sense to
me is you say if you took your political
views out of it would you still be
friends and I I don't even really know
what that means because a political view
is not just whether you like this
candidate or that candidate a political
view is not just what's your stance on
immigration politics politics is how we
all live together politics political
just means public so if you if you have
views on anything that pertains to the
public on how we live together on man
relates to his fellow man that would be
a political view and if you put
political views aside I don't really
know what you would be left with you
could be left with metaphysical views
theological views philosophical views
but but really not even because all of
those things touch on politics because
they touch on human nature and how man
relates to his fellow man so I I just I
don't think it it would be meaningful to
say put your political views
aside your political views touch on
virtually everything that you would
think about but would we be friends
outside the daily wire yes and in fact
we were next
question hey Michael I'm from America's
evil Top Hat as you say um and I'm quite
upset because I don't have access to the
new uh bent key
application and I could never with my
subscription get a uh Le of steers
tumbler and most importantly I don't
have access to the store to buy your
bestselling game yes or no so what are
you going to do about that I'm
speechless by the way guys can we get a
couple Bells here we've had two mentions
so far in the mailbag not one Bell has
gone off is Mr Davies asleep at the
switchboard over there there we go okay
I guess that'll suffice I'm very sorry
to hear that you you not able to get the
DW and bent Key Products up in America's
evil Top Hat I guess I'm not surprised I
assume that you know there's there are
Gestapo standing at the border
preventing any good wholesome sane
content from getting in up there these
days under the tyranny of Justin Trudeau
uh but I guess my advice would be that
you should move South you should don't
and you can you're going to have a
harder time moving moving south across
the northern border but if you fly to
Mexico and or Nicaragua or Guatemala or
El Salvador El Salvador is actually
pretty good now they've got a great
right-wing leader but I don't know
Ecuador well sheor is doing a little
better and whatever you got to do Escape
Canada and then come over
here and then you can get the books and
you can get the candles and you can get
bent key and you can get a very special
project what I consider to be the most
important project that daily wire has
ever commenced upon which will be
announced shortly okay let's get to some
written mailbag questions this question
up from Mike hey Smoky Mike I've been
seeing this gal for a few months now I'm
absolutely taken with her she's smart
exciting active and an incredible smile
uh and a devout Catholic my question is
how does one ask a woman to be his
girlfriend I'm 29 and have been out of
the formal dating game for some time and
there only seem to be two ways for the
conversation to go one seems juvenile
while the other seems clinical even the
term girlfriend makes me cringe any
advice here would be much appreciated
and as you are the DW Love Guru
indispensable I'm sure thank you and God
bless well if you've been seeing this
girl for months now I don't know where
the ambiguity would be I guess it
depends on how you're seeing her one
hopes that you're you know not doing
naughty things that only married people
are supposed to do but there would be
other ways of of showing signs that you
are dating each other
exclusively for one do you you know kiss
do you like smooch a little bit that
would be probably a sign that
you're you're at least da you're at
least seeing each other you're dating if
not exclusively uh are you what what
kind of events are you going to together
are you just going and getting a cup of
coffee every now and again or are you
attending a wedding together have you
invited her to meet your family maybe
not your parents but maybe your siblings
or have you brought her into your friend
group have you you know I I agree it
doesn't need to be like you're in Middle
School you say hey TI would you be my
girlfriend please um though you might be
that blunt but I just think there are
gradations of seeing each other if
you're going on walks and still being
rather koi with one another that's a
very Elementary stage of dating if you
you know smooching and you pin your
varsity pin on her jacket and you know I
don't know I don't know you take her up
to the sock hop or something you know
that would be another level and if
you're if you're going to weddings
together if she knows your family if she
has been incorporated into your group of
friends then that would be another level
and then I think you probably don't need
to talk about it too much I mean if you
find out that she's dating other guys
while doing all of that then you know
she might not be the gal for you there's
much more to get to many more mailbag
questions the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code nolles KW a check out
for two months free on all annual
[Music]
plans